when I graduate from universities and
before I you know for three years I
tried to fill in the universities so I
applied jobs for 30 times got rejected
I went for a police they said no you're
not good I went you know even the KFC
when KFC came to China come to I say 24
people went for the job
23 people accepted I was the only one
guy
and we went for police five people full
of them accepted I was the only guy that
I received receiving so to me being
turned down rejected oh by the way I
told you that I would I applied for
Harvard for 10 times rejected
I know I'll be rejected yeah sorry now
ten times you wrote them and said I'd
like to come to Harvard
and then I told myself someday I should
go teach there baby